[Music]
all right
welcome everybody as folks start to join
the space
welcome to diversity and leadership
community connect with community 2020
this is the session where we get to talk
about our first generation low income
club
one of our newer clubs on campus we are
so thrilled to have them
and we are so thrilled to have you here
as well today
i'm gonna actually turn this session
over to one of the people on campus that
i
am so so so incredibly honored to work
with
she is someone who inspires me in the
work i do every day and reminds me
how powerful the mba experience can be
so with that i'm gonna turn it over to
valeria
oh my gosh well thank you so much and
welcome everybody
so excited to be here um so i'm gonna go
ahead and introduce myself before
handing it off to the panelists to
introduce themselves i am valeria
martinez
or val for short um free gsb i lived in
los
angeles so shout out to all the socal
people out there
um favorite thing about the gsb so far
gonna be
super cliche but it's honestly the
people i've
made some incredible friendships here at
the gsb and some people here know me
better than my own family and i come
from a very large mexican family
that is very tight-knit so that's saying
a lot um so i'm gonna hand it off to
mike and arriba to go ahead and
introduce themselves
thanks val um welcome everybody uh my
name is mike kobiela i'm a nba 2 here
um one of the co-presidents of the club
along with ariba
um i wish we could see you guys in
person um but we're glad you're here
um i am originally from chicago uh and i
grew up or i grew up in chicago
um but i've spent the last couple of
years in san francisco before the gsb
and i'll hand it off to aruba
hi everyone my name is ariba i was born
and raised in pakistan
and i moved to the states eight years
ago for school
and lived in new york city before moving
to
san francisco bay area for school and
i think my one of my favorite things
about the gsb so far
is the fly community and the fly club
so very grateful for mike valeria
and the rest of this crew on campus
awesome thank you both so we're going to
start off with some prepared questions
for you all
and then we'll do that for about 15-20
minutes
and then we're going to open it up to q
a so you can use the chat feature to go
ahead and ask us any questions that
you'd like
um so let's get started um this one's
for you mike can you tell me about fly
and what kind of events or activities
does fly host yeah so
fly is a community for people who
identify as first-gen or low-income
or as an ally it's a pretty new club it
really started the year
before we got here and we're sort of
sort of been focused on growing it and
building a bigger community
right now we've got uh probably around
40 to 50 people who are actively engaged
which is about 10
of the class um that comes to these
events which
um i think is is really exciting um and
of course it's been a little bit
different
in covit times than maybe it would be in
a traditional year
um in the past we've we've brought in
speakers we've had kind of happy hours
and
group events to really kind of form that
social fabric between students who have
similar backgrounds and and similar
identities and frankly
you know being being from the background
that we are you know there's certain
things we think differently about
certain risks we can be afraid to take
um certain ways that we set our
ambitions and i think
having a community for folks like us is
really really powerful
um this year we we've changed focus a
little bit
more onto the community building because
of the challenges of
of covet so we're doing a lot of kind of
small group events
um a lot of dinners a lot of virtual
kind of support groups and
really just just finding ways to build
those relationships and and welcome new
mba students
in even though it is kind of a more
challenging year
awesome thank you so much mike um this
question is actually going to be for
both of you
so what are some recent topics fly has
been engaged with
ariba maybe we start with you sure
i think that i think there's there's a
lot of overlapping
identities that we see on campus when
you look at the fly community so there
are people from
obviously across across both genders
there are people from across
racial and ethnic backgrounds there's a
bunch of international students that
come
from a first generation low-income
background and
a lot of the discussions recently have
been around kind of the
complexities of having those overlapping
identities
and navigating all the tough stuff that
comes with that
um some of us have talked a lot about
being an international student and being
firsthand low income
and making compromises on the kind of
career paths that we can pursue given
that we might be supporting family or we
might be looking for a work visa right
after we graduate
we've talked about budgeting on campus
there's
obviously people from all different
walks of life at the gsb
and some have more dispensable income
even at school than others and so
how do you afford to pay rent how do you
have a social life
and also you know budget effectively how
do you
send the amount of money that your
parents or your siblings expect you to
send every month back home
when you're a student so lots of
conversations around
overlapping identities and lots of
conversations around just
building financial agency for ourselves
and our families
mike anything you want to add that's a
great list there isn't much to add i
would say
maybe a little bit more on kind of
career and managing finances
um i think there's a lot of research out
there that shows that
people with a fly background tend to
actually be weirdly less successful
especially if they disclose that
identity to employers
and so i think a lot of conversations
also um
revolve around kind of like how we
position ourselves and
and where we set our goals to be um as
well as i think a lot of kind of the
tactical nuance of
you know how do you come to gsb and
spend a quarter million dollars that you
probably don't have to come here
and then spend more money on top of it
to be a part of your class and
really get the same experience that your
more privileged classmates do
um i think that's kind of the other kind
of big topic that we're constantly
chewing on
yeah thank you mike and ariba that's
great great contacts
for folks um curious if you can both
share a little bit about how you got
involved with fly
and what made you want to take a
leadership role with the
organization
yeah i can maybe start there um so like
i identified pretty strongly with this
background
so my story um i was actually born in
poland and emigrated to the u.s when i
was two years old
um and my parents even though they they
were well educated in poland
none of that kind of qualified here and
was counted and so my dad's a truck
driver and my mom
started out as a janitor um and so i
realized when i came here that i'm
actually from a very wildly different
background and
even though i've been in the
professional world for a few years and
and can sort of fit in when i need to i
also was
really looking for a place where i could
be totally honest and kind of ask find
other people who are asking the same
questions that i am
um i definitely found it um so i i think
you know there's a lot more focus on
diversity in
admissions for things like mba programs
and representation
you know at every step of your career
for more
you know socioeconomic diversity i think
it starts here it starts by creating a
place where people
know they belong and and um you know
wherever you're coming from
um finding the support finding a
community and so it's kind of a
no-brainer to
come in and help this club grow because
you'll find out if you're if you're
considering mba programs you know you're
only here for two years and one year
you're a student and the next year
you're a leader on the things that that
really matter and for me this felt like
one of the most important things to
spend my time on
yeah i think mike did a great job
explaining
the reasons why some of us joined the
club um
i think for me it was it was interesting
to come to business school like mike
said and realized that
the people who are most visible
often early on in business school tend
to be of
a certain demographic profile like
oftentimes it's the people who are
playing the most beer bong or
who are like organizing the most trips
and it's very easy to feel
invisible if you're female if you're a
woman of color if you're an
international student if you're one of
the only
muslim students on campus in my case um
they were just
i think there were moments when i felt
very alone and isolated in my identity
and in my
body and skin tone and all of that and
so um for me
joining the fly club was really a way to
put myself out there
and be really visible early on as a
student leader so that
other people who enter the gsb and who
feel alone and isolated
can kind of look at you know a crew of
us and say actually
you know there's people like me here and
so it came a lot
it came down to representation and
visibility in in large part and also
just kind of keeping the community
thriving and growing like like mike said
because there are a ton of us
out there it's just that like mike said
there isn't always space for us to
truly talk about our background
yeah that's great and if i if i can add
um my two cents here so i
am also also first generation grew up
low income
my parents immigrants from mexico my dad
came to the states started off as a
janitor um at a large printing and
graphic arts company and so i
you know we were very measured in terms
of what we could spend growing up
and some of that mentality still applies
to me today is i'm thinking about
you know am i going to go on this trip
granted last year pre-covered
my am i going to go on this trip with
friends or am i going to choose to stay
on campus and enjoy you know quite
frankly everything that
that northern california has to offer
and i think that
you're going to find pockets of people
at the gsb that fit into every kind of
mold and every
spectrum in terms of spending and
hobbies and activities and so this is
certainly a place that is incredibly
diverse
and regardless of the background that
you have or your lived experiences
you're going to find people here to
truly connect with and i think it's one
of the one of the awesome things
about this community
cool okay um
let's talk a little bit about surprises
during your time with flying
or your time at the gsb in mike noribo
whoever wants to take
that first
i can go first i think one of the big
surprises kind of related to what we
were just talking about valerie and mike
was just
how many members of the fly community
there are in the class
so mike and i along with some of our
other club members kicked off a program
recently called
fly pods first gen low income bobs and
the idea is that
we meet once or twice a quarter either
virtually or in a socially distant
manner
and create space to talk about our
identities and any questions that we
have the kind of questions that we're
seeing in the chat right now
and we got i think we were expecting
maybe 10 people to respond
and we got closer to i think 40 people
expressing interest
in creating these spaces and
facilitating these dialogues i think one
of the big surprises after
kind of kicking off the experience
feeling a little out of place at times
was just
realizing that there is actually a
community of folks at the gsb who want
to have these conversations and want to
support each other
i love that answer i totally agree um
i'll also answer this question a little
bit of a different way which is i'm
surprised by how much the gsb changed
the way that i think
um i came in here with a pretty set
like mindset about what i was going to
do and what i was going to get out of it
and i think
everything that they promised right the
community the the classes the
the opportunities that was all there and
that's all true um
but for me it actually took me almost a
year to to challenge some of these
notions of what i wanted to do with my
career and ended up
you know working at a non-profit over
the summer um on
sort of fly related issues and now i'm
considering a career pivot that
is not the safe option of going to
consulting and you know having my loans
paid off in two years
um and i'm doing that because i've been
rubbing shoulders
and and having my thinking challenged by
people who
come from such different backgrounds um
that i think that will sort of be the
lesson that will be worth
the two-year journey and i certainly
wasn't expecting it coming in
yeah well should we uh should we take
some questions from the crowd it looks
like we've got
yeah let's yeah let's do it um
am i just having technical oh q a there
it is i was like i can't see the
questions
okay yeah let's start with some
questions from the crowd let's see
um we've got one from joel
how has the gsb helped you navigate the
mba as a first gen student
and what are some resources for funding
not just a program but things like
housing
transportation books etc
i can i can get a good though um i think
that
once i got in one of the first people i
talked to at the gsb
was our one of our leaders at the
financial aid department
her and um she
was just so forthcoming i had this very
frank dialogue about
kind of being first person in my family
go to school let alone graduate school
how self-indulgent it felt to you know
spend
like drop a couple hundred thousand
dollars on a degree
when you know we were still trying to
make ends meet at home and just kind of
that experience and i found that there
was a lot of there were a lot of folks
at the financial aid department who were
willing to kind of sit with me
and help me understand um how to portray
my
kind of unique financial circumstances
in my forms
so i remember attaching things like
western union statements that i
had for money i sent back to pakistan
and then most
like screenshots so like when i
transferred money to family members to
support them and
it was just really nice to have a
financial aid department that was
willing to work with me
and you know help me kind of get the
resources i needed to make this degree
happen
um i think there's also a lot of tips
that we talk about within the fly
community
around managing the money aspect of it
once you're here kind of
beyond financial aid so one of the most
helpful things for me was realizing that
there's a diversity of options when it
comes to rent so
you can essentially live about five
minutes from the official gsb residences
um in an area called escondido village
and um
your rent goes down by about i think i
paid less than half of the rent i would
have to pay if i lived in the gsb
residences so just
knowing that there are options if you
want to just you know cut back on rent
and have some money to go on trips with
friends
back when we could travel um so there's
a lot of options around kind of managing
rent
um for events that are paid there's lots
of options to volunteer for the event
and be a bus
monitor for instance and go for free
instead of you know shelling out a few
dollars to attend
um there's ta jobs on campus and no
taker jobs on campus and emergency
funding if you're
you know if something goes wrong with
your family or you need resources for
mental health
there's just a lot of kind of little
cushions
out there for for folks in terms of both
financial and
mental security yeah
thanks reba for for sharing that i think
um i think where the gsb is really good
is
when you're coming from a background
where you are supporting others or you
are
coming from a very kind of low-income
background
that's immediately before school and i
think there's another
set of circumstances that's worth
talking about which is what if you
yourself are doing
okay um but you come from a different
background than your class
um and i think that's kind of where i'd
identify is
um you know i like i'm gonna preface
this by saying
gsb is way ahead of any other business
school because most business schools
don't even do financial aid at all
but i'm someone who got zero from the
university and
their reasoning is over the next 10
years i can make enough money to pay my
loans back
and because i'm not directly supporting
anyone in my family
um i am should be able to take that
burden off and it's it's kind of a tough
pill to swallow
um but the reality is like you come to
business school to get
a high paying job among other things um
they do have programs for like loan
forgiveness for folks who go into
non-profit or
kind of public impact work um but there
is sort of a middle ground where
if you're not in that bucket you do have
to sort of
think about whether you know the cost of
school
uh will shape what decisions you make
coming out of school
um and it does kind of change your
experience in school right so
you know again with covid it's all a
little different but you know there are
a lot of trips that happen that are
super expensive right like when a third
of the class goes
before their trip before you show up on
day one and it costs two thousand
dollars for a week
you know for a lot of us it's a really
really hard pill to swallow even if we
you know are not supporting relatives
back home uh financially um
and so there's a lot of kind of tricks
of how to do business school on a budget
and it's it's frankly something we talk
about a lot
um and i think part of it is just
accepting that it's you'll feel like you
will feel the fomo right when you see
your friends posting ski trips on
instagram or
you know jetting off to vegas for a
weekend but that's that's not where you
get 90
of the value of the degree like the 90
comes from
actually getting to know people and and
like making connections through school
and i think it's just important to
recognize that like while business
schools have a big
party culture and a big travel culture
um you can get most of the experience
and it's okay to say like this trip is
too expensive for me
or you know do the do the small stuff
like you know invite your friends for a
barbecue
where everyone chips in 10 bucks for
groceries instead of going out to
a super fancy restaurant right they're
just there's trade-offs and i think it's
important to
recognize that they exist um
but i think you know like nobody comes
to gsb
and then leaves without a job and
without a high paying job um
and so you kind of just have to trust
that things will also be okay
and that like your formula will look a
little bit different coming out than it
does coming in
and i think the one thing i'll add um to
mike's point i
you know i was also one of the folks
that does come from a
low income background first-gen and i
didn't receive a lot of money from
stanford
and so i've been trying to navigate you
know my two years here and what does
that look like
for me long-term and for the support i
am going to provide my family after
business school
and at the end of the day i think
business school's a very personal
decision
um and it's almost like you know the
risk i'm willing to take on myself
and am i willing to bet on myself um
and similar to what mike said it's you
know thinking about it long term
in terms of how much are you going to
make in you know five ten years
um and what does that mean for
sacrificing you know two years
of uh for business school um
so yeah let me take a look at some of
the other questions um
there's a question here around imposter
syndrome and finding your voice
so um can i take that one yes please go
ahead i was just going to add one more
thing so imposter syndrome finding your
voice
and psychological safety this is
madison's question
madison lee that's right yeah i'm really
glad you asked that question madison
um i think this is one of the places
where gsb really shines
um i like can't compare to other
business schools but it's definitely a
strong point of this program
is the focus of gsb
is not getting you through accounting
and finance and strategy class
the the focus of gsb is on developing
the person
as a leader and so many of the classes
and especially the best classes
are really introspective and really
work through some of these questions um
and it's remarkable to see how many
people even from non-fly backgrounds
struggle with impossible imposter
syndrome psychological safety taking
risks
um so it's a remarkable community and
just to give you kind of a
couple of examples um you know there's
classes like touchy-feely where
you share crazy amounts of stuff with
your group and find
incredible kind of personal growth
through it um
i took a class called um lives of
consequence where we literally had to
write
and then rewrite our life stories to
change our internal narratives that we
tell ourselves
based on kind of like the best practices
in the research um
because it turns out that actually the
story you tell yourself very much shapes
how you think
and act in the future um and there's so
many classes
even more tactically and like paths the
power of like how do you come across as
more influential how do you write
how do you speak publicly and especially
if you're coming from a background where
you didn't have the chance to develop
those skills
gsp will teach you but it will also make
you comfortable in using those skills
to an extent that i don't think you can
get you know working or
in a program that looks very different
from ours
yeah happy to have you to add a couple
things uh i think mike did a great job
of
speaking to some of the gsb strengths as
just generally a great business school
program
um for fly students and other students i
think the
other thing that's helped me personally
when it comes to
finding my voice is just speaking
up you know this sounds kind of funny
but um
i think that it takes a decent amount of
courage for
fly students to speak up in class and
say
actually or actually not just fly
students with students from any kind of
minority background
um female students students from other
countries who just kind of speak up and
say actually
that's not gonna work where i come from
that's not gonna work for me
and i think for me like a huge part of
my gsb
experience is just kind of like dealing
with that discomfort and raising my hand
in class and
organizational behavior class and be
like actually that leadership style
won't work for a lot of women
in the industry i came from and actually
like that cultural stereotype about
people from this country is you know a
cultural stereotype and problematic and
so
i think the gsb isn't perfect and
there's a lot of
times when you know the curriculum can
feel dated or the conversation can feel
dated
and having you know compassion for the
professors who
are trying to keep up with all of the
stuff that's happening in the world and
all of the diversity in our community
but also you know standing up for your
perspective and your community and
saying actually i'd like to add a
slightly different point of view here
um that's been a huge part of my
experience and i'm really grateful to
the fly community and to
kind of students from a diversity of
backgrounds at the gsb who do it time
and again and
the great thing is every time you do
speak up and you do offer a
different point of view whether it's
virtual class and people are kind of
chatting and saying plus one thank you
or it's actual class and you know people
are snapping or nodding like there's a
lot of kind of support for each other
when we when we speak up and present a
different point of view and
that in itself is you know it's a burden
but it's also its own kind of
psychological safety and finding voice
awesome thank you both um i'm going to
take chris's question here really quick
um because i want to do a quick plug um
so
chris is asking about any prep programs
for business school
that uh prospective students can join
like the ucla reorder program i'm
assuming that's what you're referring to
chris
the other plug i'm going to make here is
for mlt mlt
management leadership for tomorrow mba
prep is an incredible program and a
great funnel for diverse candidates that
are interested
in business school so take a look at
that
um i'm happy to post the link in the
chat in a bit
but um it's it's i leveraged that
program
to apply to the business schools that i
applied to and so i highly recommend
okay um let's take a look here
um from earl can you speak on how the
gsb improved your interpersonal skills
are using your voice um
yeah i can share um so this has been
huge for me
uh the feedback that i got in my past
jobs was that i didn't speak up enough
that i didn't fight for my own i didn't
fight for my teams um and it's because
you know from day one as a you know my
first day at bain
full-time work landing in a client site
i didn't even know how to wear
the like business casual clothes that we
had right let alone tell ceos what to do
um crazy crazy imposter syndrome um
so i think as fly students
like i'm gonna try to generalize here uh
i think we tend to be really good at
reading the room and fitting in and we
tend to struggle with using our voices
more
and having our presence and i i loved
arriba's point of
like gse gives you so many opportunities
to practice that
and get really good honest feedback of
like how you're coming across and what
worked and what didn't and
what people want to know more about and
you go through so many iterations
and it starts with lead labs in the fall
quarter which everyone has to take
um and then continues through like most
of the electives honestly
um for me like i
like i just feel so much more
comfortable in my identity and and
knowing who i
show up as and and just owning it um
and i think for for this community in
particular it's
especially important yeah
um yeah i was just gonna build on your
point and say that uh there is a couple
of really awesome
programs at the gsb that kind of embody
what what mike is talking about so one
of them is called
doc um for nba jews it's every monday
for mba once
every wednesday and it's essentially
just one to two
mba students talking about their life
experiences
and people will share a lot of personal
details
and you know share experiences being
first gen low income or
being born in a different kind of place
or overcoming
a kind of health issue and it's this
a really wild um kind of
experience where you stand in front of
your classmates and you talk about
something deeply personal and just kind
of having that
program um and having other experiences
like the touchy-feely class that might
mention it creates a sculpture
where it's okay to be imperfect it's
okay to be emotional it's okay to be
sentimental
it's okay to be honest and be yourself
and you know figure out what that even
means
um so there's this really special
culture at the gsb
um that i think is is hard to find at
any other
mba program when it comes to just
interpersonal skills but also just like
being your full authentic self without
without any fear
i will also add um one of the reasons i
personally
came to the gsb was the arbuckle
leadership fellows program
so within that program um basically it's
about
60 to 70 mba 2s that are selected to
coach
mba ones through what is called lead
labs like mike mentioned
um and lead labs similar to what mike
said is really the beginning of your
journey
in terms of trying to answer the
question of why would someone follow you
and so as an mba too you help mba once
navigate
this question or at least start to
navigate this question
um and as part of that program mbhus
receive
um an executive coach or our arbuckle
leadership facilitator
so mine is actually a latino woman um
and i've gotten super close to her
in terms of discussing you know as a
latina
um in business school and in the
workplace what does it mean
for me to have a seat at the table and
what does that look like and so she's
been
really instrumental in helping me find
my voice and so
i think there's always opportunities
whether part of the article program or
outside of it to connect with
instructors and professors
and facilitators at the gsb that can
help you
navigate um this question
all right let me look at a few questions
around networking and
career resources i think it might be
interesting to raise that topic
um so um
they have some questions about what the
networking experience has been like
um and how what resources are available
for the job search
um one thing that's been really cool
about the gsb
is the fact that it's small like there's
only 400 odd students here and
what that means in practice is it's not
a really
well uh or it's not like a clearly
segmented group of people because it's
small enough that it's kind of like one
community um and what that means in
practice is like
yeah like we're all in these groups
right like we're in fly and like i'm in
like the midwest club and a few kind of
like professional interest clubs and
fellows and and all these communities
overlap and so
it's like when i look at like valeria
i'm not like oh i know valve from
fellows it's like no like i know val
from like this class and that program
and like 10 other things right
um and so the job
search process like kind of happens in
two ways like
there's a part that's like formal
recruiting through like your classic
career service like similar to what you
had in undergrad
um but there's a huge part that just
happened spontaneously and
like you know gsb really encourage you
to talk about what your interests are
and explore them and sort of you keep
asking yourself this question like what
would i do if i
didn't have financial constraints or if
i knew i was going to succeed like what
would i take on
and then as you start talking about it
people start
thinking with you and and and there's so
many crazy resources that people have
access to
like like i'm recruiting right now for
for full-time roles and
in tech and like literally every company
i can think of someone in my class knows
someone there and is like
i dropped them a slack message and i
have like an intro the next day
and i've had 100 success rate on people
responding to those warm intros right um
so i think like the class like
it's not competitive like yeah some
people go for academic honors and that's
sort of their priority but
like it's not a competing environment
like it's an extremely supportive
environment
and a lot of it happens in these like
weird unexpected
organic ways but as long as you're sort
of broadcasting into the community the
community kind of
broadcasts back to you um and like
like i'll never forget i went to the
first fly event of the year last year it
was like week two of school
and i was like oh like i'm i'm exploring
like tech in the midwest
like and one of the guys who was a
second year was like okay here i know
three people there i'm sending you
intros tomorrow
and like it led some great conversations
um
that that's i think that's like kind of
normal for people's gsb experience here
um so the flat club itself does not like
provide that many resources but it's
like because
we're not in a vacuum like there's so
much here
um that as long as you put yourself out
there like it
it's it like comes to you which is so
cool
arena do you have anything to add or
should we go to the next question you
can go to the next question i think
might
cover it really well yeah i agree um i
want to stay on this topic of
career and career goals um alina asks
how has your fly identity influence your
career and life goals
you can start with that one um i think i
so i went to a women's college called
mount holyoke
which i love to pieces um highly
recommend
women's colleges generally um i
but i think the the funny part about my
experience was that everybody around me
was
going into public service or going to
work for a non-profit and
for me like i i went to the white house
back when it was a better place under
obama um in
in my sophomore year and then i worked
at a bank in my junior year and it felt
like
that was the spectrum like i could
either you know work in
public service or i could work for like
an investment bank
and it felt like i don't know it felt
like choosing between light and dark and
it was just very
reductive and confusing and since then i
think i've realized that you can be
first and low income you can pay for
your mother's medical bills you can try
to get work authorization as an
international student in the us
and still have a really fulfilling
career that you know makes you feel
really energetic when you're getting up
in the morning and that there's
so many opportunities out there and so i
think i did start off making a lot of
choices based on
which jobs could sponsor my visa and
what jobs could pay for my parents rent
in pakistan
um but since then i think it's been an
interesting kind of explanatory
process of you know testing things out
and saying actually there's banking and
consulting and tech and product and
you know i like this thing better than
that thing and all of these
can support me as an aspiring immigrant
and support me as a
you know fly student supporting their
family so um it can feel really
overwhelming when you're starting off
and that feeling of
this is so unfair so many people around
me don't have to worry about this stuff
and i do
like those feelings are very valid but
there's just
there's just so much richness in terms
of career opportunities even
with some of those constraints that that
is easy to overlook when you're
starting out
mike do you have something to add there
yeah i mean
that's just hate like so many nerves
right um
yeah like it's hard to get used to
having privilege and being in business
school gives you a lot of privilege
and one of the ways you can use that
privilege is to go and find the exact
opportunity that sort of lets you
do something you're interested by that
will pay you well and that's consistent
with your values and your identities
right
um and
and it's like very refresh like it's not
it's not easy to find these jobs but
like
you have the space to do that um
and then the extent to which your
identity kind of like affects you like
that's a very personal question
i know for myself it's made me more
risk-averse so
you know if the idea of like starting a
startup
seemed daunting before gsb doing it with
a whole bunch of debt is even more
daunting um
and i think that's probably why like
when you look at startup founders you
know they're overwhelmingly
white male affluent individuals like
more than most other industries
um and there's a reason for that right
and
um i think i think like the world is
changing i think
you know there's a lot more openness to
diverse people
in business but i think i think there is
a little bit of a reality check where
you know you speak to alums and a lot of
them say like oh i took a safer job
paid for my school and then used my
network to like
do something crazy and other people are
comfortable doing something crazy
right off the bat and it's it's personal
um but
it's definitely there and it's helpful
to at least kind of acknowledge it
thank you mike um i want to get one more
question in in terms of
career and jobs um
laura munoz asks have you felt that
because you will be paying off business
school you need to choose a high paying
job after graduating from the gsb
that not might not be as close to
something you're passionate about
it's a loaded question laura yes
mike do you want to go first or do you
want uh yeah i'll
i'll take a first step at it uh so
speaking for myself yes
um again like i came in i accepted a
consulting offer before school started
because i was like all right i'll get
this paid for in two years and then i'll
move on with my life
and then as time were on i was like wait
i don't want to do consulting
it's a waste of my time i won't learn
that much
how can i get out of this and that's
kind of where i am i'll be honest about
it
i went to work for non-profit this
summer because i wanted to to see what
it was like to work on something really
mission driven
what i came away from was like the
number one thing i can do to support
this cause
is to make more money because it's not
like they don't have smart people who
are working on it it's
that they're short on resources right
and so
i think for me personally i've it's sort
of added another reason to the list
of why should i why i should get like a
well-paying career
first and then take care of the other
things um
and then within that i've kind of been
thinking okay well
seeing how well gsb alumni do
like consistently i'm more willing to
take risks than i was
two years ago right so i'm i'm now more
comfortable with the idea of like hey
let me get a job
that's more technical that i like so i'm
recruiting for data science which is not
the most traditional career path
but i'm like let me go do this it pays
pretty well it's a good match for my
interest
and i'll just trust that on a 10-year
horizon
it will be fine right because i figure
i'll be more successful doing
the thing i'm good at and i'll like my
career will go better than if i take
something that's short-term and
money-focused but again i also recognize
that i have
the luxury of like you know i i'm i'm
not
you know supporting family or i'm not in
some like crazy financial situation i
just have
zero dollars in savings and my parents
have zero dollars in savings and
ten years from now i'll have to be
paying for their retirement
yeah i think similar story similar story
to mike
um i i
went from slaughterings i did finance
slash consulting and then pivoted to
deck and i think that the
added um burden of being international
is interesting because there are there's
a lot of really awesome tech companies
that
um don't sponsor visas for international
students
um and so um it was i think it's been a
filter of
gender being a six-figure salary so that
i can
feed myself my family and you know
pay the loans that i'm taking on right
now also can they sponsor my visa so i
don't get
deported after i graduate so yeah fun
stuff um and so
i think those those filters have been
pretty important but
like i said careers are long like what
you do after the gsb
is not necessarily what you're known for
like 30 years from now
and everything is sort of incremental
and that's kind of how
i went about it um i spent my summer uh
working at apple
and i'm going back um and
um i'm working on on accessibility but
not
financial accessibility more like
accessibility of technology for people
who are blind deaf had a motor
disability
um and so kind of you know exploring my
interest in just making the world
more egalitarian and trying to approach
that from angles that
pay for my visa and for my family so um
i would i would encourage you to be
aware of those constraints but also just
know that they're not the boss of you
and there's you know fulfilling careers
out there that that pay the bills
and make you happy
and i'm going to chime in on this one
here
um so for me uh being the daughter of
immigrant parents my dad
actually started his own business here
in the states when he was 40.
and so i was able to see firsthand just
how difficult it is for
diverse entrepreneurs to build a
business without having the social
capital of
someone who for example comes from
stanford um and so for me
things have really come full circle
because now i'm spending my time at
stanford
um i'm actually interning at harlem
capital which is a vc fund in new york
that is dedicated to investing solely in
diverse founders so for me
it's like full circle here i am trying
to support people like my dad
that don't necessarily have that social
capital to to
raise um to raise capital and so
i had a conversation with a partner at a
vc fund actually last week and she gave
me wonderful advice that i'm
really excited to share with you all and
she shared that um
you know as children of immigrants your
parents come to this country to offer
you a better life and better
opportunities and for you to be happier
than perhaps they were
in their home country and so however you
define happiness
you should honor their sacrifices
and do whatever makes you happy and if
that's choosing a job that
pays a high salary like that's awesome
but if that's
if that means choosing a job that maybe
you take a little bit of a salary cut
but you're energized every day
that's also awesome um and so i guess
the advice here is
think about whatever it is that is going
to bring you joy and energize you and
whatever motivates you and and pursue
that
and that can obviously mean so many
different things to so many different
people
okay i love that advice pal um can i
pick a question next
yeah please please help me sort through
them there's a time
so i i see when that's a nice segway
it's asking about like dealing with the
residual shame of being
from a fly background and how that
translates into the application process
um so first of all the shame is
extremely real
right we all carry some version of our
own
but it's it's there right um
i think a huge learning from from this
whole experience has been
that owning your story and being
comfortable with it and leading with it
makes you powerful and trying to bury it
and pretend it's not there
takes away from your power and your
ability to succeed
and i the application process for gsb
is specifically designed uh to
look for people who are introspective
self-aware
humble like really hard working and and
have done impressive things but
but really aware of themselves right
it's not just the strict like resume
check
um and so i would say like if that's
what your story is about right like if
that's what really matters to you
then like just just go for it right like
take the risks be vulnerable
um because the people who read those
essays in the admissions department are
really really special
and really caring um and they want to
see who you are
right and i don't know about you guys
like that's what my essay was about
right it was
about this background um and
so i would just say just own it um like
no one's gonna ding you for it and
there's
you know i can't speak for other schools
um but here
they're not looking for you to play to
the stereotype of an mba student
in 1980s america like they want to see
who you
are right so just own it
yeah i think what what mike said it's
funny um i think there are environments
in the corporate world in the business
world where you
don't want to you know find out that
you're the only woman in the room
or that you're the only brown person in
the room and you want to kind of like
keep all your um childhood traumas going
up his first gen low income
like on the down low but your
application should not be
one of those places like i think you
should talk about any kind of adversity
you've overcome
as a first-gen low-income student how
you've handled that
you know kind of the complexities of
that identity navigating kind of
family like familial conversations
there's a question about that
um like mindset mike said you should
really just
own the story um this is you know there
are people who have to think hard about
what adversities to talk about
overcoming first and low income students
are not
not those people so really what mike
said on your story
awesome so i think very similar question
but with a
a different lens i think um from
christina
are your peers aware of your academic
constraints and how do they accommodate
slash demonstrate their consideration
hmm val do you want to take this on
yeah i can take this um so i uh
have been very open about uh my
upbringing
and all the identities that i bring with
me to a room
um so a particular
example that i can share was um before
coven
um the gsb um would essentially take a a
24-hour trip to vegas
um and so super exciting a lot of fun
get on a plane literally right after
class on
on tuesday i said i'm blanking i think
it's tuesday night
and you get on a plane and then you
party all night and then wednesday
morning you come back
and then you sleep all of wednesday um
so within that
um my some of my classmates were
actually
trying to grab dinner um in vegas and
we're selecting among very expensive
meals
um that would easily cost about 300 per
person
and so i'm just not in a position to be
doing that right now
um and the gsb is so wonderful because i
felt very comfortable
letting my peers know like hey i
actually can
maybe think about other options for that
can be a bit more inclusive
to not just me but others in the group
and
the group was so overwhelming me
overwhelmingly
open to considering other options and it
wasn't even like an awkward conversation
it was like oh yeah for sure like the
more the merrier
and then that was that and then we
started looking at other restaurants in
vegas
and so i feel like the
again the the wonderful thing about the
gsb is that
your classmates are so excited to get to
know
folks from diverse backgrounds and
experiences and lived experiences and as
long as you're open and honest and
and vulnerable people are incredibly
receptive to that
um and i'm sure there's other examples
that i can think of but
yeah i can add to that quickly um so i
i didn't go to vegas film
um because i you know just
didn't feel necessary from an economic
point of view or experiential point of
view
and i think that there's you know
like valeria said like there's options
and where to go for dinner and there's
options on how to spend a tuesday night
and
there are just people from all kind of
all kinds of like dispositions and
backgrounds so
there's a lot of um ex like acceptance
of wherever you're from um
not exactly an economic consideration
but
i think one of my um most intimate
experiences with the gsb community was
when my mother passed away earlier this
year
and i you know came back home and there
was someone picking me up from the
airport
and there was some my fridge was stocked
with food
and i you know somebody was doing my
homework
um it was just you know people kind of
like meeting me halfway and asking me
like doing stuff for me before i even
knew that i needed food in my fridge i
needed my homework done
and um not exactly kind of economic
considerations but more like mental
health considerations people are just
incredibly considerate and accepting at
the gsp partly because of this culture
of like
vulnerability and oversharing that we
that we're part of and it's 100
okay to ask your peers for help whether
it's you know on money or
or family stuff or anything else that's
going on in your life
yeah yeah that's that's a really
powerful story
um yeah i think people are really caring
i think
in my experience here a lot of people
just don't think about money and
when you say hey this trip is you know a
little expensive for me
i'm not going to go to hawaii for a week
or something
like people just like oh okay cool like
we'll see you next week
um and like nobody kind of thinks twice
about it um
but it is important to set those
boundaries for yourself like i found it
really helpful to just have like
a spreadsheet of like roughly how much
i'm
kind of budgeting for myself for this
quarter and within that not feeling
guilty and above that just telling
people like hey i can't make this trip
sorry
um and i think people are really
supportive and
i think people like might not guess that
that's even the first thing that's on
your mind
um so again like the degree to which you
want to share it um but
yeah i can't can't think of a single bad
interaction and
and i actually came to stanford for
undergrad and that was different right
like to be a part of the social scene
you know greek life going out to eat
going out to bars like non-stop
uh but i think jsp is way better because
i think people are just mature and
and understanding um
yeah thanks mike and arriba
um i want to shift gears a little bit
and talk about allyship
um because i think it's so important
across all identities that will be
represented this week
um during diversity week and so cleo
asks can you talk about the allyship
with non-first-gen students how is the
club
involving non-first-gen students
i'm happy to talk about allyship at
stanford from a diversity committee
perspective but
if you all want to address it from yeah
the flag would love to hear that
let me give you the kind of the quick
fly version which is we don't
really do it and maybe we should um
our priority is on creating a community
for students who do identify and
we very openly invite allies and reach
out across campus and
i don't know how many people in the pods
are like fly students versus allies
because it's pretty small and
confidential
um i think talk actually
like what are was talking about earlier
serves as a really powerful vehicle for
allyship because
i'd say probably you know a quarter of
the stories that i've heard in talk that
have had full you know three four
hundred people listening from our class
probably about a quarter of them touch
on fly type stuff
and people are incredibly supportive and
it just builds a whole new level of
empathy
um but again this is one of those things
where i think
we can probably do more of it um and i
think it it's up to people in the club
to decide
how much it matters to us and um
frankly like if if any of you guys you
know
come to gsb and decide it's right for
you and and want to take that on like i
think there's a huge
amount of room to to do more than what
we're doing
awesome um and i can take it from just a
broad allyship perspective so i
sit on the student association diversity
committee which essentially
um is in charge of anything diversity
related that
impacts the student experience so one of
our big events is actually
training mba one students on concepts of
diversity equity and inclusion
via this concept of pods um which are
essentially small groups of four to five
students
that have are led by mba twos who have
been trained by professional diversity
and inclusion
uh facilitators um and so as part of
that curriculum that we're building
we're actually working across all
identity groups
to build an allyship training that is
hopefully will be released
uh next year in our winter quarter and
that is basically aimed at helping
nba ones and nba jews think about this
question of how can i be a better ally
to
insert identity group here um whether
it's gender whether it's race whether
it's socioeconomic status
and so um i say all of that because
there is
so much energy within the student
community
to improve our allyship efforts across
all identities um
a lot of that was driven by the events
of this summer
um actually events that have been
happening in our country for
for many many years but most visibly
this summer
um and so i think it just speaks to
the commitment that gs beers have
to concepts of diversity and inclusion
and understanding those concepts if they
haven't necessarily been exposed to them
in the past
okay so we have about six minutes left
do you guys think we can squeeze in
another question and then
close things off sounds good
all right is there is there a question
ariba you want to okay yeah go for it
yeah
i thought the question from jimmy is
really interesting um
um if you pursue entrepreneurial
endeavors how did you find a way to
build a company
well i think there's a question from a
couple of people here about families
just like
having conversations with families i
think um jimmy alluded to it and then
kelly also alludes to it um just like
given that business school is a foreign
concept to many students families i'm
curious how you navigated conversations
with your family and then jimmy has
another one and supporting family i was
wondering if we want to talk about her
chats and our support with our families
quickly
it's a fascinating question
you guys are very creative really
hitting on the good stuff
so ariba is the question more around uh
just
how are we supporting our families now
if if that's the case for us
yeah i i was trying to um hit
do uh duplicates of one stone i um
i think the i think there's two
questions one is around supporting
family and the other one is justifying
the decision to go to graduate school
and
i was just going to add that it it did
feel very self-potential indulgent to
spend a lot of money on your education
and to explain to your family that you
were going to do this
um and in my case um i only felt
comfortable going to business school
once i had a certain amount of
savings like i did the math of how much
money i sent my family back home and one
side accumulated enough to be able to do
that for two years
um with no income i um decided to go to
business school and so the conversation
with them was very much like
hey y'all i'm doing this for myself um
your like
paycheck is not gonna stop like arriving
in the mail
um don't worry about that and and i
think they were generally pretty
supportive once
um i i was able to make that clear
but just generally um i think
i think it is hard to um
navigate these career hurdles and make
these decisions for yourselves
when you haven't had other people in
your family do that in the past and kind
of
not only just have the burden of making
the decisions but also of
justifying them to yourself and into
family members i just wanted to
be cognizant of that
yeah yeah so i had a very different
experience
that um so my parents grew up in poland
which
was communist at the time so definitely
about the opposite of having an mba
program as you can imagine
and i had a lot a lot a lot of family
pressure
to go to graduate school um it got to
the point where
you know every week or two my parents
would bring it up but like you only have
a bachelor's
you're gonna not gonna do well in life
like when are you applying to school
and they could not understand the
concept of
how freaking expensive business school
is i was like look like i have
busted my ass you know paying san
francisco rent for four years to save up
this
tiny little amount of savings that's my
like
financial security and you're making me
go to something that's gonna cost five
times what i've saved up right
um and it was it was a big source of
conflict
and like i
what made that better was bringing my my
parents
into the decision and being really
transparent and direct about like
you know like here's how much money i
have here's how long i'll be paying this
off for like here's the ways that will
limit me and
i think appreciating that like they were
on my side like
all of that was like the best of
intentions even in a world that
you know they're not as familiar with um
and so i think like finding that common
ground was was
really really important um
and like i don't think i would have been
happy here
if it wasn't my decision to come in the
end um so it's kind of funny
like i was like pushing them off for a
few years and then i eventually came
around to being like okay like i want to
go to business school for my reasons and
then they were like ah we told you so i
was like shut up
um but it was it was quite cute in the
end
um all that to say like i think it's
really important to make your own
decision and remember that
like as like i think our parents are
really influential people
in general in our lives but
we sort of have to like use our best
judgment and
kind of approach it with empathy but
you know do what's do what we think is
right in the end
awesome thank you both so we have about
a minute left
um uh mike ariba do any of you want to
share any last words of wisdom
for our attendees
if not i'm happy to share application
advice
[Laughter]
i'll just say uh if you're on the fence
about applying and belonging
is the main thing holding you back uh
you will belong here you will find your
community you will be valued
um and you will grow um so
so i i hope that you know we could shed
some light on on that and
that you can kind of have a better sense
of it
yeah uh i'll add that sometimes as
first and low-income students um it's
it's very easy to undersell yourself
because you don't always have you have
awesome parents and families but you
don't always have the kind of
role models um in terms of career and
educational backgrounds and so you can't
see yourself in certain positions
whether it's
being a panelist on this panel next year
or
you know being in the job that you're
dreaming of i just encourage you to not
undersell yourself if there's something
that you really want by way of career
entrepreneurship or school
go out and and get that thing for
yourself because you know you're
you're probably good enough and you're
probably understanding yourself a little
bit
i i i would say exactly the same thing
except without the probably like you
guys are good enough
thanks mike awesome we are a minute over
mike and ariba thank you so much and
everyone in attendance thank you all so
much
we are excited to hopefully see you all
at the gsb
in the near future and will i'm not sure
if you want me to hand it off to you
but thank you all so much a huge
huge huge thank you to our panelists
valeria as our moderator this has been
one of the most powerful and impactful
sessions we've had all week
um you didn't see me behind the scenes
but my heart was so full
and you give me so much joy to be able
to work with you so with
everybody in the audience thank you so
much for joining us we do have events
all week long and i'd love to continue
seeing you throughout